helping us to come to terms with the
past
was among the most arduous tasks
of our new nation
and archbishop des122
played a seminal role in this whole
process
at madiba's request
he led the truth and reconciliation
process
with integrity
dignity and humility
while our beloved madiba was the father
of our democracy
archbishop desmond tutu
was the spiritual father
of our new nation
in considering how fortunate we are as a
country to have been blessed
with these two global icons
we think about the lagaze street in
soweto
the only street
in the whole world
that was home to two nobel peace
laureates
we think how both
of these two icons
of our country played different
but complementary roles in forging
the nation that we are today
archbishop desmond tutu has been our
moral compass
but he's also been our national
conscience
even after the advent of democracy
he did not hesitate
to draw attention
often harshly
to our shortcomings as leaders
of the democratic state
he saw our country as a rainbow nation
[Music]
emerging from the shadow of apartheid
united in its diversity
with freedom and equal rights for all
the arch bequeath us many things
the importance
of having the courage of one's
convictions
solidarity with the oppressed
delivering on the promises made by
the constitution
and many others
but it was with
this term
rainbow nation
that he bequeathed
our new nation the greatest gift of all
hope
and forgiveness
hope and forgiveness
for a better tomorrow
hope for a country free of tyranny and
hope for a society where all the people
of south africa
irrespective of their religious
affiliation
their gender
their race their origin
could live side by side
in harmony